kids today have all kinds of things to
occupy their minds from tablets to video
games to remote control toys but one
company aims to give them something to
awaken their imaginations
after a wildly successful Kickstarter
campaign candy lab toys now makes one
simple thing wooden cars they're fun and
hip modern and retro appealing to both
kids and adults I met up with the
talented toy makers in their Brooklyn
New York work space what does it mean to
be a toy maker in 2017 so we're
designers or engineers we are retailers
we have these ideas almost like little
movies that we play in our heads that
represent the seed inspiration of our
stories for anyone used to the toys of
today often prefab and plastic these
little cars feel like there's something
new yet old at the same time they're
wooden handcrafted made with an
exceptional attention to detail and
designed not to occupy the mind but to
inspire it flad where did the idea for
this incredible to a company come from
my wife and I at the time felt that the
toys that we had access to were not
quite engaging in a sense that adults
could actually partake in play we felt
that there's something too guided in
terms of Licensing and a pre-existing
storyline so we figured that there's a
way to combine real cultural cues so the
idea of playing with cars as a kid was
that something you would do absolutely
Vlad Ragusan founded the company his
passion for both design and for cars
were driving forces but developing just
the right look and feel was a long and
winding road the hard part was coming up
with a design because it's always
difficult to see hey what would a kid
like and what would make it compelling
to them to play for a while and what
would be an adult sort of interest to
grown up as a parent to actually partake
in that ko Helder is candy labs
industrial designer he was immediately
drawn to the company for its compelling
designs right off the bat there is the
beautiful colors I think that's a really
I think that's a really key thing that
really helps them pop off the shelf and
then when you dig in deeper there's a
lot of small details that are very well
considered so you have small iconic
moments pulled from actual cars that you
can see and then this body can be
flipped from the very first model each
car has been designed and crafted not to
duplicate an actual car but to magically
capture its essence we designed this
kind of sports car orange car that we we
started out with and that has a stance
where the nose is sort of diving down a
little bit and the rear is sort of
lifted up that's because at that era in
that particular model that I was
inspired by which is in 1967 they have
spring Leafs on the back and they had a
heavy engine in the front which
naturally after a few years the car
starts to dive down a bit you're talking
about such specific details in a car
than a child
play with so it really is important to
you that it's attractive to an adult
as well it is important because
obviously a five-year-old wouldn't know
about a 65 GTO but his father or his
grandfather could tell him because they
will notice that but that's exactly the
point of our toys we want to have that
connection to real-world experiences
this is actually carved out of a solid
block they hope these elements help
create a context that enriches a child's
experience beyond just playtime we want
to give them enough of a backstory that
are interesting but not too much of a
backstory because we want them to still
have their own imagination kind of play
a big role in this when we start
designing we do start putting pen to
paper
the idea for each product line starts
with a sketch then a prototype is made
using 3d printing from there a wooden
model is constructed it can take up to
30 tries before the final version is
complete and the design team is always
looking for inspiration I think
throughout the entire process we're
keeping an eye on the research looking
at photos of existing cars going to
events if we can where we can see these
things in person and finding bits of
inspiration from that cultural era that
were inspired by from the numbers
painted on the side to the fabrics they
choose even the real rubber tires
everything is important to the stories
these toy makers want to tell when a
family buys a car what do you hope they
get out of that moment we hope they get
hours of fun and we hope they get some
really interesting conversations about
what these cars represent as an idea and
we hope that they remember some road
trips and maybe reenact that on their
play mat and we think that is the
essence of play establishing that
connection that moment that allows you
to recreate some moments that you're
cherish
and we've got the new collection here
the outlaws with us or five in this
series they're great and by the way pick
them up these are heavy cars play with
them
prices range $24.99 all the way up to
above a hundred for the collectors items
and I'm telling you every adult that's
picked these up has done that you got to
play with them and I love the fact they
recognize adults like toys - that's
right I like toys on TV maybe we lucky
you can keep one of these things